a nuclear reactor run by undergraduate
students at a liberal arts college
sounds like an interesting idea but it's
real and it's been here at Reed College
in Portland Oregon for 50 years and yeah
we're gonna put a camera in it go for it
the Reed research reactor is a trigger
reactor designs be operated by students
in science we use as a training reactor
we got it because we had a radio chemist
on Reed's faculty he thought that it'd
be really important for the students to
have access to this cutting-edge
technology that was nuclear reactors we
have a tank of 25 feet deep it's full of
around 25,000 gallons of water we think
that we have enough uranium continued
operating at our current rate 400 years
without having to change it out we
operate at 250 kilowatts which is
actually a free low power while it does
produce power when it operates there's
no way of harnessing that to make
electricity the main purpose of a
reactor is for science the kind of
research we view is called neutron
activation analysis and the logic behind
it is if you don't know exactly what
something is made out of you can make it
radioactive and then quite exactly what
it's made out of and then like work
backwards and figure out what it was
originally and then let it sit in a room
until it decays and then you have your
original thing back you can put 80
things in there drop it into a tube and
then you turn it and it turns and it
gets the same amount of neutron exposure
and then we get it out with a fishing
rod and then afterwards you have to be
very careful with it because it's
contaminated the water at the bottom of
the reactor becomes radioactive has m-16
in it that you didn't succeed but
because in 16 has like a half-life 7
seconds when the water is cycling
through it gets diffused through a
nozzle it causes the new water to let's
whirl around like this which makes the
delivery time from the water at the
bottom of the reactor to the water at
the top of the guy here just like a few
seconds longer than it needs to be so
water at the top is it radioactive and
that's one of the coolest parts of our
water system the radiation levels of the
reactor produces is actually very low
but the water provides sufficient
shielding so it's safe for us to be in
here while the reactor is operating it's
a very small reactor it doesn't get hot
enough to melt
doesn't explode so the way we shut down
our reactor in an emergency is with
something called a scram so we have a
special button it's labeled with scram
button and when you press it it cuts
power to those electromagnets and it
automatically shuts the reactor down if
someone drops their phone or some other
object into the pool normally what we do
is we get a bucket on some string and we
try to scrape the object into the bucket
with a very long stick or we wrap duct
tape around heavy weights and we lower
the weight into the pool on a string and
try to pick it up that way we have a
pretty good success rate can we turn the
lights off so we can see the blue glow
wow that looks awesome the blue glow is
Cherenkov radiation which is a bit like
the visual equivalent of a sonic boom
but there are other people much better
qualified to explain that than I am
research reactors aren't very common but
there are more than you might think
there are a couple of dozen in the
United States alone that universities
and research institutes and a few
companies this one is basically a
student society just Steven societies
with a lot of regulation and oversight
so before a year allowed to operate the
reactor you have to get a license from
the US Nuclear Regulatory Commission our
students train for an academic year
before they sit down for that exam you
actually do you think such as memorize
diagrams for our cooling system or a
ventilation system you need to be able
to play on how the physics work how to
protect yourself from radiation and how
to actually use controls that they're
reacting we license 15 students to
operate every year currently we have 30
to 40 students on staff you don't get
academic credit for working the reactor
and I think part of that is because we
get paid to work here just as a job this
is the reason why I came to read thought
it was really cool that this was a
facility that existed at a school and I
was like I'm gonna do that but I first
started a training program I had to pull
aside the training to provide the reason
said you have to explain the atom to be
from the beginning because I don't know
anything I worked really hard and I just
really wanted to know it now I know it
and I still think it's really cool and I
get to do things like operate this thank
you so much to everyone at the Reid
research reactor and in particular
violet and carried who put a camera can
do it pull down the description for more
links about Reed College and about the
reactor
I'm looking at a nuclear reactor oh wow
I have never actually seen Cherenkov
radiation Universal before it's amazing